[Music]
thank you so much for being here you're
very kind you uh you understood the the
problem it's not the first time i've
filled in for an nba player
this happens to you a lot really it's
sexual yeah
you know just a little padding in there
yeah um you know it's funny though we we
called you up and said would you help us
out because uh this situation occurred
and meta world peace can't be here and
you said i was at that game i was you
were at the game i was uh yeah i i i
don't know much about basketball uh but
i did clearly understand when he elbowed
that man that that made se that was a
man hitting a man and i
i finally understood that at least
something in the game i could lean over
to my wife and be like see now what
happened was
mr world peace god
uh
yeah um and no it was crazy what was the
describe the mood in the uh because it's
you know it's a big deal and and i'm
just curious what did you as a witness
what did you see what was the tone of
the room um it was it was really
palpable i mean he he was on that fast
break i think can you say is that what
it's called yeah
uh headed towards the net hanging from
the circle yeah the right the right
basket each basket
yes and uh and he made it and then uh he
got everyone went crazy and then uh the
other fellow came up uh next to him and
i love hearing the other fellow
this other fellow strolling along the
boulevard yes on the opposing team and i
guess in a celebratory
um
gesture
he he elbowed the man in the side of the
head
um james harden yes so you're you
because that's what he has uh said in a
tweet he said that i i i didn't see him
there i didn't see james harden there do
you believe that
if that's the case then i i think he was
doing a new kids on the block dance or
something i don't know what else would
would warrant
this move
it's a very
very 90s boy band
do you think he was channeling him is
that what i would stick to i beat the
guy up as opposed to yeah like what was
what was that was the crowd was the
crowd because some people were they were
they what are people saying at one point
they started chanting world peace um
which
is ironic i mean i i think that i think
he probably should have waited to change
his name to world peace
you know uh until after he elbowed
somebody and then it could have been his
sort of you know the reparations right
he named himself world peace and then he
violently you know took down another man
yeah
and then everyone chanting his name is
forced to say yeah so and then they but
they were supporting i don't know if
they were supporting him or if they were
supporting the idea of you know pacifism
and world peace
i don't know that's not what people
chant
okay when they
object to a physical play in basketball
they go right to the bigger the bigger
problem which is world peace yeah no i
don't know i mean
i don't know why then they were on his
side i guess
for hitting that that other gentleman
has this what is the other guy's name
james harden okay